hello we start with breaking news from
sudan where the sovereign council says
there's been a failed coup attempt the
plotters reportedly attempted to take
control of the state radio facility for
more on this heber morgan joins us on
the phone from khartoum hello there hiba
what more do we know about this failed
coup attempt
well there are still a lot of questions
about which group exactly is behind this
and the purpose of the coup what we do
know is that about three hours ago
khartoum walk up to what seemed like a
pretty normal morning with the exception
of that the one of the bridges leading
to uman which is one of which is the
twin city of the capital khartoum one of
those bridges were blocked and that
bridge leads to the arms temple of the
military now there were a couple of
tanks standing in front of the bridges
preventing civilians from crossing over
and there were a lot of ships by those
people who were trying to cross the
bridge as to why there were tanks uh
between those two bridges then came the
report that there was a coup attempt and
that the soldiers were taking over the
arms depot and that they wanted to take
over the state television and radio now
who exactly that group is and why they
try to stage a coup that's the question
we're waiting for uh to hear answers
from the sovereignty council they're
expecting to issue where they're
expected to issue a statement
uh in a short while um but so far we've
seen a lot of tweets from members of the
sovereignty council one of them being
the spokesman of the sovereignty council
himself who has called
on the people to support the military
and the transition and
other members of the government or
rather the ruling coalition of this
government are calling for support of
the transition of course this is a
government that came to power following
the overthrow of former president ahmad
bashir in april 2019 before uh signing a
power sharing agreement between the
military and the civilians so right now
there's a lot of questions on the minds
of many people here in sudan which we're
waiting to hear answers for uh
from the uh sovereignty council when
they issue a statement shortly
but give us an insight into you did
mention it briefly just then give us an
insight into the current political
situation internally and externally in
sudan
well there is a bit of tension both
sides have admitted admitted the
military and the civilians which are in
a power sharing agreement both admitted
that there are some tensions between the
two sides but nevertheless they've
always described their relationship as
something of a unique model that many
countries
can follow now uh there has been reports
of tensions between the rabbit support
forces that's the para group uh here in
sudan which is uh uh the head of that
group is also part of the sovereignty
council in fact he's the deputy head of
the sovereignty council uh there's been
rumors of tensions between his um his
forces and the military uh that that has
risen uh has caused tensions in the
capital repeatedly and then there's of
course
the the the relationship between the
military and the power sharing uh
coalition the coalition that they signed
a deal with uh in august of 2019.
there's been repeatedly war of wars
between the two sides we've seen
repeated uh statements issued by the two
sides condemning each other for moves
taken but nevertheless all sides have
repeated that they
have a unique kind of partnership a
unique structure that they're trying to
follow to ensure that sudan um actually
heads to elections and follows its path
on a democratic transition now sudan's
relationship with its neighbors has been
up and down there's of course egypt
which it had military drills with
several times over the past year but
then there's tensions between sudan and
ethiopia over the grand eastern
renaissance as well as a 3 000 square
kilometer area known as
which straddles the border between sudan
and ethiopia now again we're waiting for
statements from the army to understand
who exactly was behind the coup and the
purpose of the coup and exactly what
motivated them there's also another
thing that we have to take into account
now in the east of the country
in the state of red the state
specifically port sudan there has been a
lot of tension in fact the road leading
to that state has been blocked by the
tribe known as the bija who have
condemned the peace agreement
that was signed in the south sudanese
capital cuba last year they say that
even though there were members from the
east to sign on that peace agreement it
does not represent the demand so
internally that has been causing a lot
of tension to this government
heber how much does the economic
situation in the country come into play
here
now when this government took power
in august 2019 there were a lot of
protests that followed because of the
economic conditions the inflation was
continuing uh continuing to rise deeply
many people have complained that they
were no longer able to afford you know
basic commodities and we've seen the
rate of poverty go from 50
to over 70 percent that's something that
the government has admitted to but we've
also seen uh earlier this year the
government devaluing its currency and
floating its exchange rates to be able
to stabilize the economy according to
their words they've lifted fuel
subsidies and that has been something
that many of the official of the people
in the country have not accepted in the
stage protest uh against that but in the
past month there has been a report that
the inflation has actually gone down
and a lot of people are saying that
some to a certain degree the economic
situation is starting to stabilize so
for the past two or three months we have
not seen a lot of protests regarding the
economy talking to average people you
would hear people uh talking about the
economy saying that they still find
basic commodities unaffordable but a lot
of them are saying that they're starting
to see some changes in the economy
they're starting to see some
improvements especially since the
devaluation of the currency
heber tell us a little bit about the
mood on the street you're obviously very
familiar with sudan have you been able
to speak to anyone about their reactions
to this potential failed coup
well we've spoken to military sources to
get an understanding of what has
happened and they have said that this is
a small group and that they are
containing the situation now the work we
focus on here is containing which means
that it is still very much an active
operation that they're trying to control
then there's also uh the normal people
people who are trying to understand what
is happening
there has been a bit of traffic on the
street the uh you could see you could
send some kind of tension you know uh
that there is a bit of a difference from
everyday and this morning uh people
trying to understand what is happening a
lot of them waiting for that army
statement to let them know what has been
going under what has been happening and
what is still underway uh in the capital
hotsome and whether there is any danger
to the transition now people have been
repeatedly saying that they have always
felt that the military had an upper hand
uh in in the in the
controlling things in sudan many people
who protested let's remember said that
they did not want a military rule they
wanted a civilian rule uh as the current
things stand there is the prime minister
abdullah who is
the head of the executive council of the
transitional government then you have
the sovereignty council now to get an
understanding the sovereignty council is
made up of five military members six
civilian members from the ruling
coalition and then three members from
the armed groups that signed a peace
deal with the syrian government in
october and the southern his capital
cuba last year that's the makeup of the
transitional council and the executive
council which together at the moment
also found the legislative assembly
until a transitional legislative
assembly is elected by the ruling
coalition now a lot of people and a lot
of political parties have been saying
that they're not happy with the
situation
they believe that the military is in
control of many of the issues and now
that they are also armed groups in the
deal and in the government they believe
that the civilians are getting less and
less control nevertheless they've always
spoken about the fact that they're
waiting for this transitional government
to lead them to elections they wanted to
see uh syndicates and unions being
formed they wanted to see the the
building blocks and the foundations
being put for an election to be held by
the end of the transition so for a lot
of people who we've been speaking to
this morning there are questions as to
whether that transition is now in doubt
and whether the army will get a stronger
grip by the end of the day
what is your thoughts or what are your
thoughts on the strength of that
military you have alluded to it in that
previous answer but how strong are they
you're talking about an institution that
has been in power for over 60 years or
rather that has been in existence for
over 60 years
facing a coalition that has been in
power for less than two years now
obviously when you compare the two the
military has the upper mind they also
control a lot of companies and thus uh
can balance themselves with the sydney
economy and the ways things are managed
so a lot of people have been saying that
uh the army should let go of the
companies and the industries that they
control because that gives them a lot of
income that they should not be getting
and that they should be
on the payroll of the government just
like any other civil servants uh
obviously the guy that the army has a
lot of power especially when you factor
into the fact that it isn't some kind of
a partnership although tense with the
rapid support forces now that's the para
military group that has been leading the
uh the conflict in darfur and has been
accused of human human rights atrocities
including burning villages and raping
women so when you look at those two
groups together and then you look at the
civilian coalition which has been in
power for about two years it's obvious
to see who has the upper hand here but
then when you look at the document the
the the power sharing agreement that was
signed
that document gives people a bit of an
upper hand
there are a lot of talks about you know
how strong the executive council is how
strong is the prime minister when uh
when he's up against the military but
again the prime minister has always been
saying he's very careful not to rock the
boat as a matter of fact he has proposed
um he's made proposals to try to make
sure that this country does or rather
the transition continues and that the
country as for his words does not break
apart and that includes reforms in the
military so there has been more and more
tensions between the civilian side and
the military side and again when you
look at the institution that has uh
companies on uh under its control and
which it makes income off and an
institution that has been in existence
for over 60 years it's clear to see who
has the upper hand here
but thank you very much for your
insights there hibern morgan live for us
in khartoum no doubt we will cross back
to you as this story develops and we are
waiting to hear from the army and we'll
bring that to you live when we can thank
you hibba